Wow Avengers endgame crush the box
office made over 350 million [ __ ]
dollars and three hundred and fifty
seven millions the official number now
that's just domestically over 1.2
billion worldwide crazy but I see a lot
of people like how the [ __ ] did that
happen we did the math we did the math
and and it didn't add up
well I'm Jeremy former projectionists of
a movie theater I'm here to tell you
exactly how the [ __ ] had happened si you
Tube videos and articles talking about
how Avengers endgame could not pass
three hundred million dollars because it
was just mathematically impossible
because it was booked on this many
screens and it was over three hours long
so there weren't enough show times in a
weekend to do it but yeah they're [ __ ]
were because they're not taking very
important things into account see we
live in a world of digital cinema where
the supply is simply limited by the
demand if there's the demand movie
theaters can't accommodate it and what
I'm talking about is Avengers end game
played on more screens than was booked
for all the movie math all the math the
people were doing with the initial
bookings I believe not taken into
account the fact that those auditoriums
would sell out on opening weekend movie
theaters would be like huh how many
people are coming for us to we're
cancelling us we're selling out another
auditorium of Avengers endgame instead
of showing it on four screens we're not
showing it on five we may have three
people pissed off they can't watch us
will also sell out another auditorium of
Avengers endgame will be fine if you
want to show Avengers endgame in another
auditorium you just have it loaded onto
that auditoriums hard drive on and I
promise you by the end of Wednesday
going into Thursday every movie theater
showing Avengers endgame had Avengers
endgame loaded under the hard drive of
every auditorium they had canceling
other movies cancelling other showings
to show another showing of Avengers
endgame it was impossible to quantify
what it was going to make because that
variable wasn't taken into account and
that's a pretty huge [ __ ] variable
that could effectively double the
numbers of Avengers endgame I mean
granted other movies were shown
obviously they made money but also
showings were cut from other movies I
promise you that there are some movies
that are contractually obligated like no
you need to show this movie in your
auditoriums you can't cancel the showing
for like two weeks or something like
that I think Star Wars movies is usually
a couple months so they can't always do
that to every movie
they can do it too a lot or a movie
theater might do a round-robin kind of
tactic rather split up the showings of
Avengers endgame into multiple
auditorium so the movies that were
initially showing in those auditoriums
they still had showings throughout the
day I give you an auditorium one two and
three auditorium one showing movie a
auditorium two showing movie B
auditorium three showing Avengers end
game rather than wiping out every
showing of movie a in auditorium one for
Avengers end game by about half the
showing some movie a in auditorium one
and half the showings of movie B in
auditorium two and split Avengers end
game
among those auditoriums so movie a still
makes revenue movie B still makes
revenant Avengers end game has two more
showings for Nia's movie theaters aren't
locked into showing Avengers end game in
the auditoriums they're initially booked
and scheduled for I know this doesn't
happen right it doesn't happen because
it can't happen it's not supposed to
happen so it doesn't happen you're right
it doesn't happen it doesn't happen like
I'm a tease being sold at fireworks
dance doesn't happen people selling
their food stamps for cash doesn't
happen but it totally positively
absolutely does happen simply put a
vendor's endgame was just a bigger movie
this was an event everyone who saw
Avengers infinity war had to watch
Avengers end game if you leave the
audience wanting more you leave them
with the feeling that they need to see
how it concludes you're not really gonna
see those diminishing returns less your
movie sucks then you might and that's
how you gauge it like I've said in a
world of supply and demand the supply is
only limited by the demand and the
auditorium's that a movie theater can do
that for what's the demand how much do
fans love Avengers how much they love
infinity war how much do they want to
watch endgame what are the odds they'll
see it opening weekend so it doesn't get
spoiled for them opening weekend on
social media odds are probably pretty
good what's the love for the property
and what are the screams that it could
possibly play on in a movie theater not
screens it's booked for initially simply
bringing this up because this is a
variable and the great online discussion
of a love so any time you're out there
trying to guess box office numbers and
you see how many screens is playing on
do keep this in mind anyhow that's my
hot take on it I wanted to talk about
this angle of it because I haven't seen
anyone really addressed that angle of it
alright so Avengers endgame making over
350 million dollars opening weekend 1.2
billion worldwide what do you think
about that would every bank comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to
anymore click right here to see more
[Music]